bonjour je suis ravi d'être avec vous ce
matin alors pour commencer j'ai une
question à vous poser est ce qui vous
est arrivé dans votre vie une fois ou
peut-être éventuellement plusieurs fort
que quelqu'un vous dérange
alors bon je sais vous êtes nombreux
vous n'allez pas pouvoir tous répondre
en tout cas moi ça m'est arrivé
plusieurs fois et même ça m'est arrivé
que quelqu'un me fasse chier vraiment
mais vraiment vraiment vous voyez le et
du coup c'est c'est relou c'est super
pénible
moi je suis arrivé dans la vie j'avais
plein de projets pleins de rêves pleins
d'ambitions et il ya eu les autres je me
souviens j'étais grande comme ça je
mettais prévu un itinéraire sympa
vachement bien
et justement à cause des autres j'ai dû
faire des virages et j'ai pas aimé
donc je me suis dit mais est-ce qu'il ya
qu'à moi que ça arrive
alors j'ai commencé d'en parler autour
de moi mes amis à mes proches et je ne
sais pas si autour de chambéry 1 ça se
passe comme ça mais chez moi
en fait on est nombreux à se faire
déranger
donc je me suis dit ça vaut peut-être le
coup d'enquêtés sur la question c'est ce
que j'ai fait et je me suis mis à
observer les autres puis je me suis
observé moi même aussi j'ai lu j'ai
beaucoup lu sur la question des gens qui
dérangent
et puis aussi j'ai fait des formations
des ateliers et je me suis rendu compte
que je faisais complètement tout à
l'envers vraiment et j'avais envie de
partager avec vous ce matin le fruit de
mes investigations
parce que je me suis rendu compte qu'en
faisant les choses dans le bon sens je
dirais eh bien ça a changé ma vie et du
coup je vis ma vie beaucoup plus
pleinement et c'est beaucoup plus
agréable le père bien moins d'énergie
alors pour ça je vais vous parler de
thierry je prends l'exemple de thierry
parce que je sais que entre ce que j'ai
envie de vous
dire est ce que vous allez entendre il
va y avoir une grande différence
donc je me suis dit je vais image est ce
que je vais visualiser ce que je dis en
espérant que ce soit plus clair pour
vous donc j'ai fait venir thierry ou et
thierry mal à thierry fait remercier
thierry si tu veux bien te laiterie site
alors alors en vrai c'est pas thierry
parce que terry pouvait pas venir donc
c'est un figurant de thierry je remercie
d'air
thierry c'est un homme d'une trentaine
d'années bel homme et thierry est en
couple il ne savait pas encore qui il
est en couple avec sophie alors j'ai
besoin de sophie aussi voilà voilà ce
que vous allez pouvoir vous mettre face
à face vous voulez bien donc thierry
donc sophie aussi à la une trentaine
d'années attend ce qu'est la lumière je
voudrais rester dans la lumière
donc thierry et sophie sont en couple
ils vont être amenés à communiquer et
quand nous communiquons nous sommes
toujours 3 il ya une personne il ya
l'autre personne et puis il ya la
relation entre ces deux personnes j'ai
aussi amener la relation qui a entre
thierry et sophie c'est bien à tout lire
alors cet outil-là cette écharpe
c'est un outil de jacques salomé c'est
juste une écharpe pour montrer ce qu'est
une relation je laime beaucoup parce que
ici on peut voir que une relation c'est
comme un pont une passerelle un lien
dans lequel vont circuler des messages
donc là entre thierry et sophie c'est
une relation de couple plutôt tranquille
envoyer la relation n'allait pas mal
parce qu'il existe des relations tendues
et on a des relations aussi dominants
dominés parfois des fois ça change de
sens voilà on dirait presque andré
couple donc on va pouvoir voilà vous
êtes plus tendue donc voilà la relation
de couple qui entre thierry et sophie et
cette relation
je vais dire quelque chose qui paraît
très simple mais qui est pas toujours
facile à mettre en application
c'est que cette relation est là debout
et chacun est responsable à son bout de
la relation ici ils vont être co auteur
la relation mais thierry il tient son
bout et sophie aussi qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que thierry il
est responsable de ce qui va envoyer
dans la relation jusqu'à la moitié
et puis sophie elle est responsable de
ce qu'elle entend par exemple thierry
pourrait dire à sofia jeu j'aime bientôt
jeu il est joli ton pull aujourd'hui il
envoie un message
jusque là elle elle est responsable de
ce qu'elle entendant qu'elle peut
entendre
ah bah merci c'est gentil l'accueil ce
message de cette manière là elle peut
aussi dire sous le maïs ou moi ou quoi
je les achetais emmaüs il est tout
déchiré mon truc il soumet gueule c'est
elle qui donne le sens au message
voilà et puis aussi chacun est
responsable de ce qu'il ressent à son
bout la relation ici thierry va vivre
des émotions des sentiments c'est bien
lui qui est responsable de ce qu'il vit
ça paraît facile hein mais souvent on a
tendance à accuser l'autre est
responsable de nos émotions
donc voilà les choses sont posées pour
la relation et thierry dans ma petite
histoire thierry il invite sophie au
restaurant voilà
jusqu'ici tout va bien sauf que sophie
va arriver en retard brestois alors là
j'ai besoin de quelqu'un qui veut bien
faire le retard du récent qui fait
kiffer qui a envie de venir
c'est qu'il est volontaire allez on voit
là un retard varie faut qu'ils soient
retard en même temps c'est alors la ctu
peuvent bien venir ici et tu vas te
mettre devant sophie alors à temps comme
ça oui carrément
on va mettre le retard devant sophie
parce que thierry ne voit plus que ça
parce que c'est un énorme retard puisque
c'est un retard de douze minutes et pour
thierry c'est gigantesque c'est à dire
que thierry va plus voir sophie 1 il
voit plus que ce retard là qui prend
toute la place et ce retard là qui est
énorme de 12 minutes
ça va générer chez thierry une grosse
colère aussi j'ai besoin d'une colère
qui sait qu'il veut bien venir faire la
colère qui c'est qui est chaud pour
venir allait bien parfait après j'ai
encore besoin d'une personne et ce sera
vous voilà la colère si tu veux bien te
mettre devant thierry aussi et la colère
les deux ans thierry parce que thierry
il a essayé au départ de ce maître de
mettre la colère sur le côté et puis
finalement j'ai carrément arrivé devant
donc déjà on voit qu'il ya du monde au
restaurant il ya thierry à sofia le
retard et à la colère et est ce que ça
vous est déjà arrivé de d'un jour
rencontrer quelqu'un comme ça qu'il ya
une réaction démesurée pour un événement
donné qu'ils pètent un câble pour pas
grand chose est levé la main si vous
avez déjà vu ça chez quelqu'un voilà
alors merci c'est toujours plus facile
de voir chez les autres que de voir chez
soi donc vous vous l'avez observé chez
les autres certainement que les autres
que l'on observé chez vous aussi d'avoir
des réactions un peu démesuré bien c'est
ce qui se passe pour thierry thierry va
vraiment se mettre en colère contre
sophie à cause de ce retard là il va il
va l'accuser il va lui dire il va lui
demander pourquoi elle est art arx a pas
intérêt à se reproduire que la cause
d'elle ça va ce mal se passer maintenant
au restaurant que ils vont passer un
mauvais moment et tous que ça
t'intéresse sur le produire parce que et
que si encore il ya une prochaine fois
en tout cas il va l'amener à ceva la
culpabiliser à tous il va tout faire
bien comme il faut et 7 en fait thierry
au départ c'est quelqu'un qui est plutôt
calme
donc il se surprend lui même mais là il
n'a pas pu faire autrement mais en tout
cas quand il fait ça on voit bien qu'il
est au bout de l'autre rive et au bout
de la relation à l'autre et voudrait que
ça change l'autre côté ça va jusque là
alors maintenant je vais vous montrer ce
qui se passe en coulisses
en fait en coulisse thierry ne le sait
pas mais il à l'intérieur de lui une
petite blessure j'ai besoin d'une petite
blessure
si tu veux bien venir faire la petite
vous pouvez vous vous reculez un peu non
voilà fort qu lien alors un petit
blessures si tu veux bien te mettre
accroupi ici pour l'instant parce que
alors il est accroupi parce que pour
l'instant thierry n'est pas au courant
qu'il a cette petite blessure il l'a
jamais vu il le sait pas et en fait le
retard de sophie c'est comme un grain de
sel d'accord qui vient se déposer sur la
blessure est ce que vous voyez la
sensation que ça peut donner
ça pique ça fait mal ça fait chier ça
c'est super désagréable et du coup quand
ce grain de sel vient se déposer sur la
blessure ça va ça va réveiller la
blessure et quand la blessure se
réveille ça appelle là les émotions ici
c'est la colère voilà et du coup qu'est
ce qui fait ma quand il se laisse
envahir par son émotion et du coup il va
accuser le grain de sel
le grain tel qui est là sauf que en fait
un grain de sel qui se dépose sur une
peau saine on est d'accord que ça fait
pas mal soupire ça assèche un peu la
peau mais ça fait rien du tout alors en
fait on a toujours deux choix et thierry
a deux choix soit il peut décider de
passer toute son énergie à accuser ce
grain de sel de lui faire mal
extrêmement mal et de vouloir changer ce
grain de sel soit il peut décider aussi
de regarder où se déposent de grain de
sel alors ça veut dire qu'en premier
d'abord on regarde les motions qui
arrivent là bonjour ces vraiment comme
ça que ça peut se passer en vrai je sais
ça paraît facile mais je vous assure
c'est pas si facile que ça bonjour
émotions tiens sensations corporelles
qu'est ce qui se passe dans mon corps
koala j'accueille ce qui se passe déjà
voulu ça va mieux
et puis ensuite l'émotion va nous
inviter à les regarder la petite
blessure ou la petite peur enfin voilà
ce qui est venu se réveiller là parce
que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que si
vous avez envie de vivre vos vies
pleinement
il faut déjà être capable de s'accepter
pleinement et nous avons tous comme
thierry nous sommes constitués d'une
multitude de facettes multicolores
simplement on a des facettes un peu plus
lumineuse que l'autre et des facettes un
peu plus sombre que l'autre et bien
c'est accepter pleinement c'est accepter
aussi les facettes sombres c'est
accepter elle y tonton à faim publique
jolie blessure c'est aussi accepter que
bas il ya des choses qui sont blessés en
nous il ya des choses qu'on n'a pas trop
envie de montrer et plus nous acceptons
ça et plus la cicatrise elle se plus là
blessures se cicatrisent ok je pense on
est pas mal vous pouvez aller vous vous
installez un plan mais votre relation
avec vous je vais continuer tout seul
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que je voulais dire je
voulais dire que c'est comme moi vous
n'avez pas envie de perdre de temps et
d'énergie
je vous invite plutôt que d'accuser le
grain de sel chez les autres plutôt
regarder là où se déposent de grain de
sel alors parfois céder petit grain de
sel parfois c'est la fleur de sel
parfois c'est du sel grossier parfois
c'est un camion benne mais à chaque fois
ce qui fait mal c'est pas le sel c'est
là où ça se dépose et je vous assure que
c'est vraiment un changement de regard
qui peut changer votre vie et changé
votre manière de vivre votre vie
ça paraît un peu facile comme ça un peu
psychologies magazine comme dirait mon
mari mais c'est vraiment comme ça que ça
se passe à chaque fois que vous oserez
retourner le regard à l'intérieur de
vous et de vous dire mais qu'est ce qui
est dérangé en moi ça n'empêche pas
qu'on peut mettre leur grain de sel à un
moment donné deux côtés ça change ça
ouvre complètement les choses c'est
comme une petite quand on est blessé qui
de l'est sur notre corps il se guérit
tout seul
simplement faut déjà qu'ils aient
conscience qu'il ya une petite blessure
si notre corps en a conscience on a vu
au key à sa main il envoie tout ce qu'il
faut pour guérir eh bien là c'est pareil
est ce que je peux accepter ces petites
blessures qui à l'intérieur de moi et
puis ça va ça va plus je vais m'accepter
plus ça va guérir
je voulais dire autre chose je regarde
le temps en même temps je vous invite si
vous pouvez de temps en temps ou à
chaque instant pour les plus courageux a
tenté de faire ça essayez de vous
regarder à l'intérieur de vous alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est que il va y avoir
encore plein de grain de sel dans votre
vie on va nous en balance est encore
toute notre vie en vous et moi aussi
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'on va lui balancer du sel ça
sera une occasion rêvée pour apprendre à
mieux nous connaître et apprendre à
mieux nous accepter et d'apprendre à à
vivre nos vies pleinement réinventer nos
vies c'est tout le meilleur que je nous
souhaite